Bienvenidos a la entrevista de Franz 24
nuestro invitado hoy es George Shop
principal consejero político y jefe de
gabinete adjunto del presidente de
Ucrania por los acompaña desde kiev
Muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
Gracias por recibirme señor Alemania y
Estados Unidos han aceptado enviar
tanques de guerra a Ucrania ahora
Ucrania quiere aviones de combate y
misiles de largo alcance
se está discutiendo al respecto con sus
aliados
Ucrania esperó mucho tiempo la decisión
sobre los tanques de guerra
es muy bueno que se haya tomado y que
ahora lo que llamamos la coalición de
tanques cuente con más de una docena de
países
es muy importante porque tener los
tanques de guerra occidentales en el
campo de batalla es un gran cambio
el tipo de armas que usted Menciona los
misiles de largo alcance y los aviones
de combate son el tipo de armas que nos
hacen falta en el campo de batalla
no tenemos aviones de combate
occidentales modernos y tampoco tenemos
misiles de largo alcance
como lo dijo mi presidente en la reunión
de Rammstein la última vez esa reunión
de Rammstein se convirtió en una reunión
para decidir sobre los tanques
la siguiente reunión de Rammstein
planeada para febrero debe estar
orientada a tomar una decisión sobre los
aviones de combate
En definitiva estamos trabajando de
cerca con varios países occidentales que
tienen diferentes tipos de aviones de
combate y esperamos obtener un resultado
positivo
una posible opción es Polonia ya que
indica estar listo para darle a Ucrania
aviones de combate f-16 y la otan está
de acuerdo
podrían esos f-16 de Polonia ser un
resultado concreto rápido
bolonia no es el único país que tiene
aviones de combate f-16 lo repito los
f-16 no son la única opción de aviones
de combate occidentales que tenemos
usted mencionó el acuerdo de la otan
creo que a veces se especula demasiado
sobre la necesidad de contar con una
decisión de la otan el secretario
general ha dicho varias veces que los
países tienen el derecho soberano de
darle Ucrania el tipo de armas que
necesita
el gobierno del país es el que decide si
entregarlas o no
A veces lo que ocurre es una falta de
coraje o de valentía para la decisión lo
repito esperamos resultados positivos
las necesitamos ahora necesitábamos ese
tipo de armas ayer las necesitamos ahora
mañana de inmediato para poder empezar
la contraofensiva y acercarnos a nuestra
Victoria
como acaba de decir algunos países toman
sus propias decisiones el canciller
Alemán o Dark souls dijo que Berlín no
enviaría aviones de combate a Ucrania se
podría argumentar que también había
dicho que Alemania nunca enviaría
tanques a Ucrania está decepcionado por
la declaración de Alemania o cree que
esta vez también pueda cambiar
estamos muy satisfechos con la decisión
alemana sobre los tanques de guerra le
agradecemos a Alemania esa decisión
incluso teniendo en cuenta que Alemania
ya había tomado decisiones sobre los
sistemas de artillería
Alemania no es el único país en tener
aviones de combate modernos En mi
opinión también podemos acudir a otros
países de la Unión Europea y de la otan
para que nos den el equipamiento que
necesitamos
la otra arma que piden son los misiles
de largo alcance podrían quizás ser
útiles para que Ucrania apunte a más
bases tropas e infraestructuras rusas en
crimea por ejemplo
eso podría representar un cambio en el
campo de batalla
sabe tenemos todo el derecho de apuntar
a cualquier objetivo militar lo enfatizo
objetivo militar en el territorio de
Ucrania nunca apuntamos a un objetivo
que esté fuera del territorio de Ucrania
fuera del territorio soberano de Ucrania
todos sabemos Cuáles son las fronteras
de Ucrania desde el 24 de agosto de 1991
que también incluyen a crimea
en el terreno Parece que la situación ha
llegado a un punto muerto Ucrania ha
dejado de obtener Victorios militares y
algunos Están preocupados de que Rusia
esté planeando una gran ofensiva
alrededor del 24 de febrero
Esto es algo que le preocupa al ejército
ucraniano de los servicios de
inteligencia
esa información no sólo es de los
servicios de inteligencia de nuestro
país sino también de nuestros aliados no
especularé sobre esto pero es algo muy
serio al mismo tiempo usted habla de un
freno de las fuerzas armadas ucranianas
yo lo describiría de la siguiente manera
podríamos perder el impulso
tomamos muy buenas decisiones frente a
la situación en el campo de batalla
Durante los últimos seis meses liberamos
casi el 50% del territorio que Rusia
capturó a partir de la agresión del 24
de febrero del año pasado
para no perder el impulso de nuevo
volvemos a la cuestión de las armas que
se necesitan porque al empezar una
contraofensiva primero se necesitan
sistemas de artillería para empezar la
batalla de artillería y cuando se tiene
éxito Con la batalla de artillería se
empiezan a utilizar tanques de guerra y
vehículos blindados para llevar el poder
principal al campo de batalla
teniendo suficientes sistemas de
artillería sistemas de artillería de
mediano alcance suficientes municiones o
suficientes tanques de guerra o
vehículos blindados podríamos haber
empezado esta ofensiva Ayer hoy o
incluso mañana y tener aún más éxito en
el campo de batalla
pero de nuevo creemos en los esfuerzos
Unidos de nuestros socios para
entregarnos las armas
el jefe de Estado Mayor del ejército de
Estados Unidos declaró tener serias
dudas sobre el hecho de que Ucrania
pueda recuperar todo su territorio este
año en 2023
tiene la intención de demostrar lo
contrario
Recuerden que algunos expertos militares
dijeron al principio de la guerra que
Ucrania no aguantaría más de tres o
cinco o incluso una semana frente a la
agresión rusa
Hoy estamos a casi un año del comienzo
de la agresión rusa
no solo resistiendo en el campo de
batalla también hemos tenido éxito y
definitivamente queremos que la victoria
ocurra en 2023 Y tenemos todas las
razones para que así sea
su presidente dijo que la participación
de Rusia en los Juegos Olímpicos de
París 2024 reflejaría que al parecer el
terror puede ser algo aceptable
boicotearán los deportistas ucranianos
los Juegos Olímpicos de París si Rusia y
también Bielorrusia logran participar de
alguna manera
si el comité olímpico internacional
permite que los atletas rusos o
bielorrusos participen en los Olímpicos
de París de 2024
no solo los atletas ucranianos podrían
boicotear este importante evento
deportivo sino también otros países
civilizados
los atletas de otros países civilizados
pensarían dos veces si aceptar la
posibilidad de estar en los Olímpicos
con atletas que vienen del país agresor
ruso
no solo se trata de Ucrania hay que
entender que esto no sólo se trata de
deportes
solo por mencionar un dato muchos de los
atletas rusos en realidad vienen de las
fuerzas armadas Son miembros de las
fuerzas armadas de la federación rusa o
de las fuerzas del orden de la
federación
Imagínese a los atletas franceses en el
mismo terreno de triatlón con
representantes de las fuerzas armadas de
la federación rusa
o con atletas que no solo no están
haciendo nada en contra de la agresión
rusa sino que en la mayoría de los casos
la apoyan
última pregunta se supone que debe haber
una Cumbre entre la Unión Europea y
Ucrania en kiev más adelante durante
esta semana con el presidente zelensky
los líderes de la comisión europea del
Consejo europeo su Primer Ministro dijo
que Ucrania quiere convertirse en
miembro de la Unión Europea en los
próximos dos años obviamente Estos son
un objetivo ambicioso hace unos meses el
presidente francés dijo que pasarían
décadas antes de que Ucrania ingrese a
la Unión
cree que Ucrania será realmente un
miembro de la Unión Europea dentro de
dos años
sabe le hemos demostrado a todo el mundo
que los ucranianos a veces pueden hacer
Milagros y si me pregunta por los logros
para la integración europea recordemos
Cuántos días pasaron entre la solicitud
presentada por Ucrania para ser miembro
que se hizo el 28 de febrero del año
pasado y la decisión sobre su estatus de
país candidato que se tomó el 23 de
junio
recibimos ese estatus en tan solo 115
días
no diría que sea imposible con lo que sí
que estoy de acuerdo es que según
algunos expertos críticos debemos pasar
por todos los pasos de la integración
europea para que este proceso tenga
credibilidad
y estamos totalmente listos estamos
terminando las siete recomendaciones que
nos dio la comisión Europea
estamos esperando el informe de
evaluación que saldrá a principios de la
primavera y después de que ese informe
sea positivo que estoy seguro de que lo
será podemos contar con el siguiente
paso que son las negociaciones de
adhesión para que Ucrania se convierta
en miembro
y después veremos cuando empiecen las
negociaciones la historia puede ser
diferente y sí estoy de acuerdo puede
ser muy rápido ucraniano empezó de cero
cuando aplicó para ser miembro de la
Unión Europea A diferencia de otros
países que quizás puedan necesitar
décadas para ser miembros de la Unión
Europea
y como conclusión qué tan importante
sería eso para Ucrania
tiene una importancia crucial sería un
momento decisivo convertirse en un
miembro de la Unión Europea o
aproximarse a este objetivo también es
uno de los pilares de la victoria de
Ucrania frente al agresor queremos ser
parte del futuro europeo y no del pasado
ruso parte de la Unión Europea y no de
la unión soviética y es lo que
lograremos
Gears Muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado en la entrevista de France 24
desde kiev la capital de Ucrania y
gracias a ustedes por la sintonía
[Música]